- He's setting up his cards.
I start opening
up these big boxes and
setting up Wizard of Oz
and Catwoman toys,
you got to understand
we're juniors in high school.
Brandon looks over,
he goes, "I'm done."
(Jordan laughs)
I go, "This is the future."
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
The book I'm coming out with
early next year
is called Crushed It!
It's a follow up.
- [James] Oh.
I didn't know that.
- And the reason I'm
doing it is you're right, man.
I don't think I ever
want to get too far away from,
there's a real correlation
between doing things
around your favorite things.
It's just easier
when shit is bad.
Like I'm looking forward
to the 0 and 16 Jets season.
I really think that everybody
who's listening has been
passionate about some
sort of thing in their lives.
Something!
Whether it was Atari.
Do Steve Adubato's show.
Classic New York personality.
Little bit of a
gloomy day here in New York.
Got a bunch of
interesting meetings.
Feeling really tight.
For example, Pokémon.
If you read Crush It! in '09 and
you decided to build a
blog which later became the
video blog which later became
the podcast around Pokémon.
That was like a era where
Pokémon was in the culture
but not too crazy.
Just Pokémon, right?
If you became the
foremost Pokémon gal.
Sally the Pokémon gal
and you just owned it.
And you were just getting by.
You had to have a side
job but you'd go to Comicon.
You show up at shows.
You'd get an occasional weird
$500 sponsorship on your blog
but you were a good
businessperson and you actually
made a little bit more.
And you're trucking along and
then Pokémon GO comes out and
you're now on CNN and on Fox and
all these places and now you're
getting paid $5,000
to give a talk about it.
The world would've walked
into you instead of you
walking to where the money is.
Everybody's listening right
now is looking for trends,
oh these spinners are cool.
They're trying to walk to where
the world is now and by the time
they get there
the world moved on.
If you go to your thing and set
a fucking flag on your thing
I genuinely believe
there's a lot of moments
where the world comes to you.
Every kid I grew up with who
got talked out of playing video
games 'cause they had be
a doctor or lawyer by their
parents could of had the talent
to make $10 million a year being
an e-sports star.
But in 1988 to 1993 who the hell
knew that e-sports was coming.
Right?
Love it.
- [James] Oh, when
Crushed It comes out--
- [Gary] Yeah,
we'll do something.
We'll do something.
Thank you, man.
Thank you.
Take care guys.
How bad? Cool.
Take care, man.
("This Is A Hit" by Kyle)
Random thought, one thing I've
been very fascinated about with
Snapchat is their non-adjustment
to something that I think is
very important which is what
Facebook has done
in their environment on
Facebook and Instagram is given
users the option to be able to
do all forms of content.
Short, long,
long video, short video,
written, pictures.
I think that the platforms have
merged into each other, right?
Facebook has merged into where
YouTube and Snapchat has played
has become a complete publishing
content infrastructure and
I think for anybody that's going
to compete at the highest levels
independently, whether it's
Google or Apple or Snapchat or
anybody else, Amazon, anybody
or someone who emerges tomorrow,
the next Snapchat or Instagram.
They're gonna have to
give flexibility to the users.
I think you start
with something narrow and
then you build on top of it.
I think we forget that you start
with something narrow and
you build on top of it.
McDonald's had three
products when they started.
You know?
A drink, fries and a burger.
And I think that a
feature from Instagram,
a picture and a filter is great.
And I think Snapchat was
incredible which is why it
caught traction but I do
think there's a maturity level.
It's kind of the way
think about VaynerMedia.
What we did with
30 people culturally,
output changes at 80,
changes at 800.
I think people hold onto things
romantically that got them there
without realizing the thing
that's gonna get 'em to the next
level is to break the
thing that got them there.
And so, I have no insight into
what Snapchat's thinking about
more flexibility
but I'm sitting here,
this is why I had the thought,
I want to do some content for
Snapchat but I'd like a
little more flexibility.
I love what I can do there
but when the consumers have an
alternative and that's what
Stories in Instagram have done
for them, I think you
need to build out like,
you know, I want to
make a six minute video
for Snapchat right now. I do.
Something to think
about on the macro.
I used this Snapchat example
as the framework for the macro
which is please don't allow
yourself to not evolve on top of
the thing that got you there.
I believe that there's very good
entrepreneurs in the market and
I do believe that their apps
and businesses are underpriced
because they're in
the market of Dublin.
And so I think
it's an opportunity.
It's not that I'm this great
noble American entrepreneur who
wants to be fair to
everybody in Dublin.
It's because I actually think
I could get a good deal because
I think people do
underestimate other parts of
the world not
named Silicon Valley.
That's correct.
When you build a lot of
businesses they don't impact
your future businesses, right?
If I built Starbucks, I wasn't
going to be able to build.
Like to me, what I've been
trying to do is build something
that is useful for me in other
and future behaviors and that
excites me and
I think I'm on my way.
I like attention.
You know how flattering
it is to take a selfie.
I like all that.
But I also like when you talk
and a lot of people listen,
it allows you as a talker to
listen 'cause you get a lot of
feedback and I learn
from my community every day.
I get consumer
insights at scale.
Listen, like I said back to
what we were just talking about,
eventually the work
is gonna prove itself.
I didn't by accident
invest in Twitter,
Facebook, Tumblr, Uber, Snapchat
before a lot of other people
even knew it existed.
That is not by accident.
I didn't buy, this is
something nobody talks about
'cause it's lost in history.
I didn't by accident
bet the farm
on Australian,
Spanish and New Zealand wines
when nobody else
was doing that, right?
I'm not, I'm not hanging out
with these influencers and
up-and-coming hip hop
celebrities and artists for
kicks and giggles.
It's not happening by accident.
(bottles lightly jingling)
I think to your point the thing
that I like is I've
noticed a lot of times brands,
humans add more fire by
jumping in so
I do think trading it.
I think being prepared for
whatever the response if there's
momentum back to us being
concerned about it is important.
But I think watching it
every second and
ironically I do believe
9 out of every 10 times.
I mean the news
cycles in our society today
are stunningly short.
Great, awesome.
Hi.
- [Woman] Hey, Gary.
Thank you so
much for joining us.
- Happy to be on.
So, I'm an entrepreneur.
Born in Belarus in
the former Soviet Union.
Came to the U.S.
when I was three.
I think quality is actually
tied up in people's ego, right?
I think people like
to think they know and
so quality's subjective, right?
I love the glasses
you're wearing right now,
by the way,
little quick complement.
Others may not and so
things are subjective, right?
And so, I value
speed over quality
'cause quality is fake
before it goes
out and speed isn't.
- [Woman] Gary, patience is a
big thing that you promote and
it's one of the biggest
things we struggle with.
How does somebody stay patient?
- I'm not sure to be honest.
What I would say is this
though, you have no option.
Patience is practical.
Like what are you gonna do?
You know, it's gonna play out
the way it's gonna play out.
And I would also say try to
put yourself in a position to do
what you love, right?
I feel like I'm so in love
with the process of being an
entrepreneur that I'm even
slowing down my financial impact
because I love it, right?
I love holding out for it.
I often make the joke
of I love the foreplay of
entrepreneurship, right?
It's a long process.
Like I love that.
I love it so much
I want it to last forever.
I secretly don't
want to buy the Jets,
right, because I feel like the
game that I put out in front of
me would then be
accomplished so, you know,
I think that loving what you do
allows you to love the
process which then allows you
to be massively patient.
If you're doing this because
you want a million dollars,
you're in deep shit.
("This Is A Hit" by Kyle)
Great, so what
can I help you with?
So let's have John K,
Brandon, you and
Danny here in my office
for 30 in, not next week
but the following week.
We should also,
DRock, you should also
make a Facebook commercial.
You take the lead
with Brandon and Andy.
Let's get it done.
But I want, get
somebody at Vayner to act.
- [Andy] Cool.
- Cool.
- [Andy] When we first
started this it was just--
- [Gary] I remember.
- We need to use the email.
- [Gary] Alright, let's do it.
Now what's it gonna cost me?
What's the family discount?
(group laughter)
Whether that bias is true or not
here's what I can tell you.
There has never
been an ad agency,
and that's what we are, we
just happen to look the part of
something a
little bit different.
- [Man] Yes.
- That is more committed
to the end result
than this company.
And I think that
if you peel away
a lot of what's going on,
a lot of what's manifest, and
I do not believe (censored) or
(censored) or
anybody decided this.
I think this is human
behavior of running businesses
over the long term.
The thought that
there are humans
that work at these
agencies that have the
audacity to think that they've
synthesized the proper strategy
and then they are the unique
couple of human beings that get
to interpret it because it is
100% humanly subjective.
And then they are the same,
another group of human beings
within that same organization
are the ones that get to
interpret the insights and
strategy into a creative output
and that the cost associated
with that and the distribution
of that is smart
business in 2017
runs the gamut of
obnoxious audacity
to downright stupidity.
- [Man] Mhmmm.
- [DRock] How's your day goin'?
- [Gary] Literally the noble
rationale to why I'm so excited
about this investment, I'm
mainly most excited because it's
not very noble because I think
you're gonna build a big fuckin'
company and I want to make
money but the noble part is
I genuinely believe in this in a
real way and I don't think it's
just Upper East Side moms.
The whole world should do this.
When I say it, I'm being selfish
because I already know firmly
it's gonna be and so
I want the historical,
I say it not because
of the investment.
I made the
investment because of it.
- [Woman 2] Right.
- I say it because
I know it's going to happen.
And I believe that you guys are
operators and you will figure,
when I tell you that it could
end up being a billion dollar
fashion brand, great.
I'm agnostic, I just
know it's gonna happen.
Team's broken up in a
lot of different ways.
Chris's world, he's the only one
in here that's on the influencer
team at VaynerMedia proper which
works with brands and things of
that nature, Gabe
runs a small business.
Gabs runs the division
that charges brands
$25-30,000 a month for doing
what VaynerMedia used to do,
now does for millions.
We're going back
to small business.
I wanted him to meet in case in
five or seven or nine months you
guys decide to do this or we
feel like we're really rolling.
I feel like we've
just finally got it.
And then Andy and
Dunk are on my team.
It's art.
- [Man] Mhmmm.
- [Gary] But it's math and art.
That's what we've built here.
That's why this is special.
It's the first machine
agency that gives
a fuck about
Zynga and Nike. Right?
It gives a fuck about
Living Social and Groupon,
like it respects that.
- [Man] Mhmmm.
- [Gary] But also knows
that if you don't make
a Where's the Beef? commercial
you're also vulnerable.
If it was all math, some company
would've won a long time ago.
- [Man] Yeah, right.
- Got it?
It's a pleasure.
How are things?
- [Paige] Good.
- Thomas.
- Thomas, good to see you, man.
- [Thomas] Good
seeing you as well.
- Hi.
- [Naomi] Naomi.
- Naomi.
- [Naomi] Makeup and hair.
- Hi, how are you?
Good to see ya.
- [Paige] For sure.
- What are you
guys doing in town?
- [Paige] Oh gosh,
for a lot of things.
I came in for an appearance.
And then I had Complex
Magazine, Mac meetings.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
Very cool.
And how long have you two
guys been working together?
- [Paige] Two years.
- [Thomas] About
two years now, yeah.
- Awesome.
- [Thomas] Yeah.
- [Gary] How did
it all start for you?
- Well, social media
kinda kick started it for me.
(Paige and Gary laugh)
- [Gary] I love it.
And so what is, kinda always
my first instinct is there
anything, I assume you
guys have context for my,
I know you have some context.
Is there
anything that potentially
I can help you guys with?
Anything stand out? Anything as
you guys are navigating through
this that I can be a help with?
Like look, there's a reason
I have The Million Dollar Man
action figure here.
When he was in
wrestling in the '80s he said
everybody's got a price.
I think it's important for you
to price in a way that speaks
against your strategy.
Here's what I mean by that.
You're being
selective with brands.
I have a funny feeling you're
gonna spend a lot of times
trying to justify whey you like
XYZ brand if they offered you a
million dollars for one post.
- [Paige] Right, right, right.
I see what you're saying.
- So what I'm saying there
is you should come up with a
pricing strategy of what's the
number that gets you to start
debating and you should
actually price that way.
Because then you
have all the leverage.
- [Paige] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Got it?
- [Paige] Smart.
- So that would be
a pricing strategy.
So appearance, you got
paid to appear somewhere.
- [Paige] Yeah.
- How much of that do you
want to do or not want to do?
I mean that's awesome.
- [Paige] I love to just
meet people in person.
- [Gary] Honestly, I think that
she should do whatever the fuck
she wants and
then she'll dominate.
I'm worried that she's
overthinking and holding back
certain shit that she wants.
One minute, I promise.
I think that she's holding
back a thing or two 'cause she's
smart and she understands
what the audience wants.
So, it's not that I want
her to do something.
It's that I want her to do what
she actually wants to be doing.
Got it?
It's a subtle
little thing there, right?
I don't think every woman should
be about empowering other women.
If that's what they love,
then they should do that.
- [Thomas] Yep.
- [Gary] Like,
she might love sports.
She might like cuisine.
I think she just needs to be
her 'cause that will create
so many more avenues.
- [Paige] Right.
- And that's what the cliche
move that people with your size
influence and your genre and
your look aren't doing enough of
which is why they're
getting commoditized.
It's why I tell all the media
people that have meme accounts,
if you are making fucking videos
with white tops and (inaudible)
you're just commoditized.
I have no idea
what your talent is.
They're all the fucking same.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Got it?
Like filming you with three
people for a minute in some sort
of business setting
or casual setting,
more of you.
The reality TV stars
that are winning the most
have a lot of looks.
That show would not
work if it was the same
scene over and over.
- [Paige] Yeah, that's true.
- Got it?
- [Paige] Yeah.
- There's clearly a lot
potentially for you to share.
So, it's more that, right?
Like your version is what I
think people are making mistakes
of which is they're picking
a platform that's trendy and
they're going with it.
And they're winning in the short
term and they're going to lose
in the long term. Right?
I just want to know
every aspect about her and
I want that in play.
It's why I'm winning the most.
Awesome,
nice meeting you guys.
("This Is A Hit" by Kyle)
- [Man 3] Hi.
- Hi. Nice to meet you, man.
Actually, Scott, come on in.
The fuck?
(group laughter)
Nathan, what are you doing?
- [Nate] I'm learning
a little bit.
- [Gary] I mean it's about
time you learned something.
(Scott laughs)
I'm going to a
three hour meeting.
And then I'm
seeing Brandon Warnke
who along with my dad
is running Wine Library.
Talk a little Wine Library
stuff and then home.
So good day. Productive.
You've been
filming all day, right?
Yeah, yeah.
- [DRock] Mhmmm.
- Anything interesting?
Top secret meeting
with a yellow ghost.
I remind everybody, I don't say
I'm the best skier in the world.
I don't say that shit.
- [Jordan] It was like
you were saying the other day,
you talk shit
but you back it up.
- I talk shit about the most
narrow of things which is it's
the dollar rack.
You don't know
about the dollar rack.
Me and Brandon did a card show.
There were these little racks
that came out that you could put
cards in, I bought a couple.
It's like a nice
display thing for your table.
Our lives were our table.
Your Instagram
account was our tables that
we rented at a card show.
And we would try to
make it really good.
I bought this rack
and I put the dollar rack.
And then I put cards
that were worth 80 to $1.20,
80 cents to $1.20 and
I would really
set it up nice and
Brandon, here's (laughs).
The best part of mine and
Brandon's career as 14-year-olds
was this is basically the same
sitcom every episode which would
be we would show up once
a month for some new show.
I would have
some cockamamie idea.
It'd be 7 A.M.
We'd be eating doughnuts and
Brandon would be making fun of
the idea of like,
"This is the stupidest."
And to his credit
he'd be like,
"Listen, your stuff
normally works but
"this idea has not chance."
And then three hours
later, it'd be 11 A.M.
and all these people
would be at the dollar rack,
here I'll take three of these,
five of these and he would be
next to me and he'd be like...
(Jordan laughs)
- [Brandon] Don't forget
I worked for a perfect display.
Everything was pretty and
organized and he would outsell
me every time.
(group laughter)
Except one show.
Clinton Holiday Inn.
Oh, North Hunterdon High School.
- [Brandon] You were grounded.
- Out of nowhere my guidance
counselor who never spoke to me,
I spoke to her.
She never spoke to my mom.
My mom never spoke to her.
The only baseball card
show that our high school
had in four years.
- [Brandon] It was a big deal.
- Huge!
It was like Coachella
showing up to your house.
(Jordan laughs)
It was the only baseball
card show at our high school
and they had a
Phillies second baseman,
Mickey Morandini show up.
We prepped mentally for
months and physically for weeks.
(Jordan laughs)
It's the Wednesday
before the show.
We both pay for our tables
and my guidance counselor calls
my mom and tells her
that I'm a piece of shit.
I mean I don't
know what she said.
- Yeah.
- But she basically
said your son has no future.
My mom grounds me
and doesn't allow me
to do the baseball card show.
- [Jordan] Oh.
- Brandon,
I'll never forget this.
You know, no cell phones
back then so I had to wait for
Brandon to come home.
And I'm calling,
the show is Saturday,
the show is
from 9 A.M. to 6 P.M.
I know he'd be
home by 6:30 but
I'm calling starting at
4:30 and the old school.
I called 100 times.
Finally I get a hold of
him at like 7:55 that night.
And he's the best guy.
I'm like, "Hey, hey," he's like,
"How you," like he's the best.
"How you doin'?"
I'm like, "Fuckin'
this is the worst."
I'm like, "How'd it go?"
He goes,
"I had the best
day of my career."
(Jordan laughs)
"I sold every
Frank Thomas Stadium Club,
"every Frank Thomas Leaf."
He just goes nuts.
He like crushed it.
- [Brandon] It was good.
- No, the end of your career was
the Old Bridge Fire Station.
- [Brandon] I was already out.
- You were out,
you've heard this.
Where I talk about how
I sold all my cards and
bought toys and comic books.
The show where I unveiled it
was the end of his career.
So we do the show, it's in a
fire station in a small town.
I didn't tell Brandon
that I had this strategy,
he's setting up his cards.
I start opening up these
big boxes and setting up
Wizard of Oz and Catwoman toys,
you got to understand
we're juniors in high school.
Brandon looks over,
he goes, "I'm done."
(Jordan laughs)
I go, "This is the future."
I was literally
like nerd culture.
I nailed that.
Like in hindsight.
I fucking nailed it.
Nobody thought about
Marvel movies and Star Wars.
I fucking nailed it.
But we're juniors in high school
and we now care about girls.
We're like different now.
And Brandon's barely holding on
to even do baseball card shows
'cause that's nerdy enough.
And here I am,
I'm like the craziest.
I'm like putting
out the Smurf toys.
I'm like,
"Gargamel, what's the problem?"
(Jordan laughs)
We did this show,
me, him and the owner of a
baseball card store in his town.
So he's like the
real dealer in the middle.
I'm to the right,
Brandon's to the left.
We have so many classics from
that story including I bought a
case of shitty
1990 Donruss cards
and they both shit on me.
They were like laughing
at me when I bought the case.
I bought the
whole case for like $40.
There was like 10
boxes or 20 boxes,
20 boxes, 180.
I'm sorry I bought
the whole box for $80 and
it was the
worst set of all time.
- [Brandon] You got to
understand (inaudible).
- Donruss.
- 1990 Donruss.
- Bernie Williams was the
best card and it was $1.80.
- [Brandon] You could get the
whole set of like 600 cards,
the most valuable
card was like $35.
It was literally,
like regardless.
There was no reason to buy it.
- So I buy a case from a guy.
- [Brandon] A case!
- A case, 20 boxes worth.
- [Jordan] Holy shit.
- And then I take a paper
like this and I write a sign.
Donruss 1990 boxes.
I'm actually
going to replicate it.
Bernie Williams rookies.
- [Brandon] And
then it was like a set.
- And I was like Griffey, Bonds.
I just wrote names.
- [Brandon] Right.
- Clemens.
- And then I wrote,
this is where, this is
where he lost his mind.
I wrote $19.99,
X'ed out, $9 a box.
This is literally what I did.
- [Brandon] It wasn't
worth a dollar a box.
- And then I put
it and then the boxes.
And they were like when
I tell you the two of them
were literally like
schoolgirls at a playground
being like (laughs mockingly).
It had no chance.
Literally over the
next three hours that
stack of boxes was gone.
- [Brandon] I'll take a box.
- I'll take a box.
I'll take a box.
- No way.
- Creative is the
variable of success.
- [Brandon] Oh yeah.
- That's fucking amazing.
- Creative is the
variable of success.
I'm gonna take a picture of this
and post it on my Snapchat.
Everything's the same
thesis which is how do you stop
somebody who's busy
(group laughter)
and has choices,
how do you stop them from
other options and pick you?
And that's what
I do in a feed. Right?
- [Brandon] What you do in what?
- Why do people stop
for my shit on Instagram?
Great night with Brandon.
We were supposed to get Wine
Library work done but we talked
about old baseball
card war stories.
DRock you have to edit basically
that entire baseball card war
stories into a video because
we need that for history.
Brandon's kids need to know
what kind of warrior he was.
Good night,
got a lot done.
Good day.
Feeling good.
That's it.
I got nothing else.
("This Is A Hit" by Kyle)